hello in this video i explain to you
how you can calculate the one factor real variance
analysis by hand without mesz repetition
and we'll start with
that right away but let's take a
painting course at this example let's say
we measured the reaction time of a lot of test subjects
we would like  know how much variance or
scatter we can explain from the reaction time
by
forming these three groups group 1 group 2
and group 3 in this case on the
left side, for example, we can
explain a lot of variance with these three groups because the variance
within the  groups very small we
have in this group only a small
deviation of the test person from the
mean value in this group and in
this group however the mean values ​​of
the individual groups deviate very strongly
from each other
we have exactly the opposite on the
right side here we have
within the  groups a very large variance,
however, is the wah  l
very small between the groups the mean values ​​of
the individual groups do not deviate very
much from each other to put it simply,
the basic principle of the variance analysis is that
on the one hand
we have the variance within the
group and on the other hand the
variance between the coop mean values
so and now let's take a close look
at it we now want to calculate the app value and the p
value for the variance analysis of the hand for
this we first need the
mean value of the variable
reaction time i.e. the mean value of all
data we get this in this case simply
by  we calculate three plus 10 and so on and
so forth +76 and divide by the
total number of dates in
this case that is 24 dates this
gives us a mean value of 5.3
now we know that the mean value of
the variable response time is 5,  3 is
furthermore we still need the
mean values ​​of the individual groups, so
we calculate the
mean of the groups in our
case we take for the first group a
mean of 25 for the second group
a mean of 8 and for the third
group a mean of 5.5 so we
have group 1 group two in group 3
and we just calculate the  mean
of this data from the mean of
this data and the mean of
this data next we can
calculate the sum of
squares total the squares total tells us how big the
spread is in the total variable
reaction time so we sum up
how much each individual person of
deviate from the mean value
we get this by calculating iks - the
overall mean value squared
and then the sum of all people
in our example it is three
minus 5.3 which is the mean
value squared +2 - 53 squared and so
on and  so on until we get to 6
, ie 653 squared
so we get a total of
157.3 next we want the
squared sum  me calculate between the groups
so how much do these
groups fluctuate between each other for this
we simply calculate the mean value of the
individual groups - the overall
mean value, quarter that and sum
that across the groups in our case
we get 25 - 53 squared
plus
8 - 53 for  square plus 5 5 minus 13
degrees and the result is 121.3
we also need the squared sum
within the groups,
i.e. the fluctuation in each individual group
and then summed up across the groups for
this we calculate how much
each individual person deviates from the mean value
all values ​​​​of this group - 25 c
squared summed up and all values ​​in
this group - 8
summed up squared and all values ​​in this
group minus 5.5 squared and
then also like that for me so we can do
all that we come in this case
36 out the variance explanation
now results from us
calculating the total course in between and here we come to
0.77  out so by dividing it up into
the groups we can explain 77 percent of the
variance
we also need the
mean squares for this we
simply calculate the squared sum by the
number of degrees of freedom
this gives us 60 67 for the mean
squares between the sums and
for the middle ones  squares within the
groups 1.71
we can now finally calculate the ef value
with mq in between mq within
and we have an f value
of 35.3 9 here
so we have now calculated the experienced by hand
now of course we want to
calculate the p value
we need to either keep the pH value and the zero
hypothesis or
reject it.
here there are two options,
either we define the significance
level and together with the significance
level, the degrees of freedom of the numerators and
the degrees of freedom of the denominators,
we can then calculate the critical value
or  we simply take the
fw value that we have  and
together with the degrees of freedom
between the groups and the struggle for
freedom within the
groups we can then calculate the ph value you can find
this small calculator on
datatec there you can easily
enter the values
then you get your results out
here we can already see that  the critical value is
actually 3.4 67, so if
our value is greater than this value,
then we reject the zero of the
hypothesis, just like when we calculate the ph value
, the p value is less than
0.001 and therefore less than 0.05
and we live with the hypotheses
we can now compare all the results
with a statistical software
like data tab we see
the results that we
calculated on the left
side and the results from datatec on the right side and
these results are of course correct  About
a
here we have the sum of the squares
with 121,36 and 30 and 157 and we have
the mean of the squares  with a
denef value of 60.67 and 171 we keep it at
35 39 and the ph value at less than 0
001 so i hope you liked the video
feel free to watch the other videos in the playlist and
we'll see you next time